or not and then when you saw we weren't
awake then what did you think i thought
it was probably
okay
so let me translate all of that for you
good
morning guys
we just woke up and tycho what he was
saying was he woke up first he walked
out of his room and he checked in our
room but notice that we were sleeping so
instead of going inside like he normally
does he's never done this before this is
the first time
we have a growth spurt everybody um
instead of oh thank you what is that
massage
oh thank you thank you
so instead of jumping on the bed and
waking us up he saw we were sleeping and
then he waited outside in the hallway
right outside our door
and then you said that we were still
sleeping so you went back to your room
and then you came back outside and you
waited outside again
the whole thing
now i went back to my room again and
then i came outside
and then i wait there i see
so we said the same thing you look like
it looks like carnage yeah oh is that
good or bad
good oh awesome i'm happy
um
so papa's still sleeping he was in
california shooting jk news he came back
last night like at around
midnight close to one he ended up he's
like texted me around like 10. he was
like hey i'm so tired i'm just gonna
pull over across the
i'm gonna pull over on the side of the
street um and i'm gonna yeah let's get
water
i'm gonna take a quick 30 minute nap he
did that
delayed his um arrival
oh so he's sleeping thank you you're
right you're right okay
and then tiger was talking about
um
water because we sleep with the heater
on upstairs and if you don't know
now you know but yeah the heater
dehydrates you water you can eat again
yeah you can feed
yes because you're dehydrated so um
um
yeah we sleep with the uterine which
definitely dehydrate dehydrates you and
within things which is already pretty
damn dry so we wake up with supercharged
let me see your lips poke her up
yeah
so
jeff was that your nose whistling
breathe
dude again
um but yeah chapped lips is usually a
pretty good indicator that you're
dehydrated
do it in your ear okay
i'm gonna have it terribly yeah okay
[Music]
do it again
there's a lot of whistling
yeah so we're gonna drink some water wow
it took three minutes to explain all of
that but we made it
what are we doing today
playing okay oh right well watch this
you just told me this because papa's
sleeping
okay well certain rules apply sometime
okay let's get some water
you're the best
thanks dude
good morning
okay
yeah so we're at the garage right now
and this is the other thing was talking
about that he
that he wanted to play the game in my
car um i drive a tesla and the tesla
cars come with i'm so sorry i'm so sorry
come with games
i'll close it i'll close it
oh you got it
okay so let me see your car
that's a new car yes wow it's beautiful
this hot wheels oh it's a hot wheels
okay let's get it started
let's get it started
let's
excuse
oh my gosh
that's not the oh yeah that is a real
one no
there it is
look at that look at that huge ball
another bag and then
right there yeah let's go
this is the first time we play this game
not at jiu-jitsu practice because
usually so you can get that because i
need your train you don't need to train
oh the gamer for jiu jitsu
oh okay okay
okay
so normally what happens is yeah
baby card
so what happens is i pick him up from
school at three his registered class is
not until four
we're not here or not i know how is he
going to find us
okay right now we're on level three we
just passed level two we're not the best
but we're getting there huh yeah we're
getting good at this game
yeah we're getting good
we should be good
you can get way good
better way better
um
so yeah i was just saying oh yeah he
gets out of square three
and his jiu-jitsu is at four but
everything's so close here
if you think so close here that um
it literally only takes like 10 minutes
to get to his just to class so for like
30 40 so we'll go get snacks
and then um we sit in our car and this
is the only time he can play this game
until today
look at him he's actually pretty good
it's a pretty fun game
[Music]
oh man you gotta get that health get
that health boy
there you go
so you gotta get these bad guys you
gotta kill them yeah but not me but mama
do that you're a good guy you gotta you
gotta rescue those guys but okay we're
doing one thing at a time yeah because
you are the dead
oh yeah he's getting let you he's gonna
confuse
you yeah
hello
oh dad hey hey hey where are you going
hey
hey
hey come on i like the commentary good
job
hey you here you can book me
hey
oh yeah okay
hey
okay i need to get this person he's a
good guy
hey
you want to get that you want to get
that there you go laser that's a laser
[Music]
hey
hey
hey don't pass me hey can you stop
patching me stop it
there's nothing this is this hey hey
arika where are you going
where are you going hey what are you
going to call
that big bubble shield
yeah but it's gonna it's gonna get my
power down right yeah you're trying to
okay
i got 100. yeah
good job
i got 100.
okay my turn
look who finally decided to wake up
look at that
[Music]
and we're watching what are we watching
i know what do you think about that
tycoon
jump to the pool
oh that's awesome
[Applause]
how come you're almost 40 years old on
all fours
monkey enjoying
some
i was really craving some argentine
argentinian argentine food and we found
a spot called
grinconde buenos aires never been here
before super excited we ordered this
staple that at least i know is the
staple empanadas with an entrance and
we'll see how it comes out and it's
really cool because i get to practice my
spanish even though argentinian spanish
and mexican spanish are different you
know we can communicate and it's the
type of difference of like someone from
the us versus someone in the uk like we
can understand each other but there's
some of those words and accents and
stuff so it's pretty cool to get to
surprise my spanish here did you
practice your spanish with your
enthusiasm
and then i said
salad
bro you didn't even finish that one i
was saving that last one and there you
are
empanadas have arrived and i'm so
excited because they are scorching hot
and they look delicious look at the
inside of this one it's juicy as meat is
that a bell pepper or olive that looks
like a pea and this one's like ham and
cheese
it's so hot like i can feel it in my
hands but i really want to eat it so i'm
just gonna go for it
screw it
and this is why women outlive men
another thing is the kitchen is right
behind us and it feels like as soon as
it's done they just spring it out look
at that
where the guy is is
the kitchen
so i'm gonna wait a little bit and then
i'll
i'll report back
i it mama
it's gone
they're so good it's delicious
very very good
the ham and cheese yeah ham and cheese
it has garlic cheese
ground beef oh the uh the beef one not
the ham cheese i'm so sorry beef polo
um the dough is so good on this and then
just the chimichurri i don't even know
if this is the way you're supposed to
eat it but i do but the chicken cherry
is so fire
we got some rice potatoes
and some salad or salad as you would
like to call it but do the honors
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's a little
bit salt but
very juicy right there
and take the guys spaghetti balls
after some food getting some boba and my
cousin put me on the new new so he's
from taiwan so he has super high end
boba connoisseur taste buds
like myself and he was like we're
driving through vegas and he was like
what there's a tiger sugar here and i'm
like why what's so sick about that he
told me that this is the new new in
taiwan and it's popping the lines are
always out the wazoo like crazy and i
think the one in seattle or something
wherever he's at
um it's always like a two-hour wait so
he was like we have to try it and i
tried it and i love it it's so good that
it's just only like a milk and a boba
and brown sugar that's it very simple
ingredients not even tea or anything
which is cool because then i get to
share it with the little monkey dude so
i'm gonna get some
go
all right so this is what it looks like
if you guys get it they're next level
because they have two different boba
sizes
so the mouth feel is insane there's a
big ones and small ones this is brown
sugar they use a super high quality milk
and you got to mix it because it's hot
at the bottom and it's cold at the top
well it's hot from the hot the warm boba
yeah and it's not hot it's warm it's
warm
and good to my little monkey dude in my
heat and mosquito
look at that face
oh man you can't believe it you can't
believe it
you took his mouth yeah i poked it right
in the middle try it taste it see if you
like it
oh careful
is it delicious
i think you're missing it's careful like
when you're drinking it don't drink it
don't don't squeeze
your turn
how excited are you really excited you
know me i love boba and i feel like my
diet is going to come around the corner
in just like a month or two so god
try to like get the most out of it
possible bam
and just kidding
the different size bobo next level
awesome no thank you i'm full it's
delicious
my little cutie asian man forgive me
[Laughter]
what are you doing
well with your son not on yourself where
was your hand what was your hand doing
earlier just crusted this part of the
thigh oh god please stop
what are you laughing at
what time it is
that's what i was thinking that's what i
was thinking get him get him get him
[Music]
nah dude i'm holding the camera man i
mean my doctor told me to just take it
easy
and not play
see you later
it was nice knowing you
[Music]
i don't know why i said that doctor
thing
it's not true i don't even have a doctor
not out here at least we just moved here
we don't have anything
whoa whoa that smashy smash sound
yeah
[Music]
why are you putting your toys in there
are you watching him do this the whole
time no we're playing other games
look at how many toys just came out of
here
hey toy guy where'd you bring me i bring
your cars let me see what kind of cars i
got
oh whoa how much do i owe you toy guy
for free what
thank you dude thank you
you can deserve it
i deserve it let me see you how can you
be wearing glasses toy guy yeah
oh it's sunny outside okay it's your
uniform
all right toy guys see you later i'll
call you if i need more toys
hey don't bring my toys toy guy
yeah
oh thank you dude
bye-bye
all right so taika wants to play this
game where he sells me toys but i have
to call him
all right ready
[Applause]
hey toy guy
hey um so i have a i have a birthday
coming up for my mom
and i want to buy her some toys can you
what kind of toys do you have today
[Music]
you got what kind of toys
spiderman toy oh but it's for my mom
[Music]
do you have any do you have anything for
girls like it's my mom like what toy can
i get my mom
um
okay you don't know what you have you
don't know what toys you have um
oh my gosh she loves cats okay how much
is it gonna be
for candies
candy how many
three you got it okay what time can you
come over and bring me the the the
present five at five
okay i'll see you at five bye
hey
[Music]
okay
oh okay what do i get
okay i don't need this spiderman
yeah but i can't
how about i give you one candy
okay two candies for what the two cats
only okay here you go no okay thank you
i don't want the spiderman thank you i
know i want this oh sorry okay go back
okay
got the wrong currency no no okay
okay i want the cats i don't want the
spiderman here you go
oh thank you is it for free yeah thank
you
you guys see the glasses do you guys
want to see what happens behind the
scenes of what he's looking for yeah
okay i'm still here i'm gonna enjoy your
party oh hey
okay let's party together
[Music]
oh
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay i'm vlogging what did you want to
do
yeah
wow
look at that robe cutie mama but the
shower was getting crazy and they just
literally on and on and then that one's
a bit and then i went back in the water
from yesterday
so two different things happen okay the
first one monkey
is
since we're doing a lot of construction
on our block
and that's the one
well let me explain it
okay so to explain tyka's point he is
right the shower was going on and off it
was going crazy
but that's because um when they were
doing construction on the house they hit
a water pipe so they broke the water
pipe so they turned off all the water on
all our houses
so then when they turned the water back
on it started
oh because the workers broke it yes yes
exactly but then what papa's doing is
something different
papa is adding you know what papa's
no
hey
monkey he's naked underneath there so i
had to cover your eyes
don't lift that up you're not wearing
underwear because you're supposed to
take a shower
no so we'll pop up monkey can i tell you
what papa's doing
so what papa is doing is adding a water
softener so it's not broken he's adding
a water softener so that your skin
doesn't get so dry
that's what he's doing so
he's like i lick your bags and you have
such dark circles you're so sleepy yeah
oh
but
but my shot was broken too your
shoulder's not broken
no none of your pipes work really good
dude but
my shower is my shower goes crazy now
which shower in your room yeah when did
you turn it on i i got a bathtub shower
oh bathtub shower that's fancy
my mom
oh what about your mama what does she do
you you always that's a bathtub and
that's the shower and then
and then i got a bathtub shower it's
gonna be awesome it is awesome yeah but
yeah but it there's a shower oh there's
a shower and then and this is
then this is the bathroom this is our
bathtub i see okay so do you understand
what papa's doing yeah
i love kid conversations it went from
i didn't do it
wow doesn't that hurt your feet
stretchy oh okay cool
what okay
so yeah if you didn't catch that papa is
adding a water softener which is that
bulgy
there because the water in vegas
is so harsh so not only is it dry as
heck out here but it's the water it has
so many
minerals in it that like
it dries our skin
like crazy so i think it's the harsh
water
coupled with the dryness that like
wrecks us so papa
yeah oh
so i just put up all the threading tape
this is the manliest thing you've ever
done
in 2022 what are you talking about
what's the manliest thing after that
see no things popping out it's leaking
it is leaking you're right all right
i gotta go back up there and fix it yeah
[Music]
let's go
now
this dude's fixated on the pipes the
pipes work buddy the pipes are good yeah
because you're because you're a beast
i don't think you're saying
that i don't know i that's the first
time i've heard it
am i a beastman
well well papa fixed the pipes um
i wanted to show what i picked up
because of the harsh water over here
um i picked up
i i found out about
lonnie ish
lonnie edge
laniage i don't know
laniage
from target
i got their face wash and it was so
perfect
which makes which reminds me right now
that i don't have it or use it anymore
and i'm like wait why did i stop anyway
um so i saw this one before because i
was picking up some makeup just because
i ran out of just my regular makeup um
and i saw that they had like water let
me zoom in here
this one water sleeping mask
it sounds amazing so it hydrates because
i need it
it brightens and it softens so i haven't
tried it yet clearly it's still in the
packaging and then there's this one
that is radiant c cream i put it on
today and it felt really good so it's
supposed to brighten even tone and
obviously
moisturize and then i got this guy
which is part of their water bank whoa
don't drop that on the floor duty
that's a magnet but yeah don't drop it
on the floor okay oh that's really cool
yes it can shatter
um
and it's eye gel
for all skin
i just figured i don't know our eyes
just
get crazy
[Applause]
[Music]
anyway and then the last thing i picked
up which i was really scared to get so
that's why i got the smallest size
is drunk elephant
and it's another moisturizing
moisturizer so
it's supposed to strengthen and
moisturize so we'll see how it goes i'll
report back
but yeah it's been a struggle
what are you talking about he said see
you later everyone
here
he said she can like beat me but yeah
let's see how this works out
what i would do to get your energy in a
bottle and just drink it every day i
would pay
so much money okay because i
what is going on
i love it i'm happy thank you i love
that okay